hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused channel my name is Paul today I
want to talk about knowing your learning
style most people rely on other people
or on their materials to teach them but
I want you to be empowered to be able to
direct your own language learning that's
why today we are going to look at your
learning style and how to use it to
learn more efficiently different people
learn differently we all have a unique
learning style that is based on the type
of sensory information that we prefer
these kinds of sensory information are
called
learning modalities and there are four
of them some people say three I'm going
to say four they are visual auditory
reading and writing and kinesthetic you
can remember those learning modalities
based on the acronym vark VAR k students
generally have a dominant modality but
they do use a combination of all the
different modalities some people will
say for example I'm a visual learner but
really what they mean is that I am
primarily a visual learner with some of
the other modalities as well there are
some people who don't really have one
strongly dominant modality and they call
those people multimodal learners they
have a multimodal learning style I
happen to be a multimodal learner I
don't really have one really dominant
modality but my least dominant modality
is the auditory that's the one that I
prefer the least now preferring a
specific modality doesn't mean that
that's the only way that you can learn
it doesn't mean that you can't learn in
the other modalities just means that
that's the preferred modality for you
that's the one that engages you the most
that's the one that you can relate to
the most so it's usually the best way
for you to learn visual learners tend to
prefer learning using images videos
charts maps graphs and so on and often
they see images in their mind when they
are reading or listening auditory
learners prefer to learn by listening to
others speak by having discussions by
explaining things out loud sometimes by
recording a lesson and listening to it
again in order to review read/write
learners learn visually but specifically
through text and they enjoy learning
through textbooks through articles
through dictionary definitions through
writing journals through writing
articles through writing blog posts in
their target language read/write
learners tend to be quite good with the
patterns and the syntax of a language
and they can look at a sentence and
analyze the different
within it quite easily kinesthetic
learners are engaged when they are
experiencing something physically with
their body they tend to like acting out
real or simulated situations through
movement and through roleplay and since
emotions are actually physical
sensations kinesthetic learners are
quite engaged by emotional sensation so
emotional impact will help in their
learning and retention you may already
have a good idea of what your preferred
learning style is but in case you don't
you can take this quiz right here and
get an idea of what your preferred
learning style is when you know your
preferred learning style it becomes
easier to understand why you're not
motivated why you're not excited to be
learning and why you're not learning as
efficiently as you could be most people
rely on their teacher or on materials to
teach them but your teacher and your
materials often don't target your
preferred learning modalities have you
ever had a teacher who just talked and
talked and talked and talked and talked
and talked even if your teacher had a
pleasant voice unless you were an
auditory learner you were probably bored
to death another common situation is
that kinesthetic learners are sometimes
made to sit in their chair at their desk
for 90 minutes straight and after about
30 minutes of that you're ready to pick
up your chair and throw it when I make
videos for laing focus I try to include
elements that address all of the
different learning modalities so that I
can engage as many people as possible
for the visual modality I try to include
interesting images and backgrounds and
charts and maps when appropriate for
auditory learners I try to speak in a
clear and engaging manner and include
some music and sound effects for
readwrite learners I try to include some
text headings and key points on the
screen and for kinesthetic learners I
try to create some emotional effect
through some of the things that I say
and through some of the music and the
way that I choose and mix it in through
some symbols and imagery that I include
in the video when you do self-study you
can choose to use your preferred
learning modality to help you be more
engaged with the material and to help
you retain the material better if you're
learning materials don't match your
preferred modality then you can adapt
the materials by filling in the gaps and
creating the parts that are missing in
your modality for example if you're a
visual learner but your materials are
mostly text-based then you can imagine
images of the words and
sentences that you are practicing
actually see the situation in your head
as you are practicing the language so
that the language and the imagery become
associated if you're an auditory learner
but your materials are mostly text-based
then you can imagine the auditory
component inside your head you can hear
the voices you can hear the voices being
expressive you can also chant sentences
to yourself you can sing sentences to
yourself if you happen to be a readwrite
learner and you are using an all audio
program like Pimsleur for example then
you can try to imagine the words inside
your head actually see the letters of
the words when you are saying them out
loud that might be hard to do at first
but when you get used to it you can do
it and then you will be connecting the
auditory with your preferred learning
modality of read/write if you are a
kinesthetic learner and your materials
are mostly text-based then you can
imagine yourself going through that
experience that you are reading about in
that sentence or in that text try to
actually feel what's going on and
experience it in your body even though
you're imagining it you can try to feel
those sensations you can use body
motions and gestures to learn new
vocabulary and you can use body motions
to act out the language that you are
studying you don't have to just stick to
the learning materials that you have you
can interpret them and adapt them to
your own learning style and use them in
the way that's best for you so knowing
your learning style is important because
it can help you adapt materials and
create new activities for yourself that
keep you engaged and help you retain the
language that you are studying so I
recommend that you find out your
learning style and you use it to your
advantage today thank you for watching
the Lang focus Channel have a good day
Oh
yeah